Traductor: C E Blanco Santini
Revisor: Paula Motter
En una cabaña destartalada
al borde del bosque,
marido y mujer vivían desesperados.
La mujer había dado a luz
a su décimo tercer hijo,
y la familia, cada vez más numerosa,
se estaba quedando sin comida ni dinero.
El padre caminó hacia el bosque
a reflexionar sobre su problema.
Después de pasar horas
deambulando entre los árboles,
se encontró con dos sombrías siluetas.
La primera parecía ser el Dios del hombre
y la segunda parecía ser el Diablo.
Ambas figuras ofrecieron
aliviar el sufrimiento del hombre,
y servir de Padrino
de su hijo recién nacido.
Pero el hombre rechazó las ofertas;
no le confiaría su hijo a quienes
juzgaban la vida humana.
Se adentró aún más
en el enmarañado matorral.
Aquí, en la parte más oscura del bosque,
el padre vislumbró una tercera figura.
Un rostro demacrado con ojos hundidos
dibujó una torcida sonrisa.
Era la Muerte misma,
que venía a ofrecerse de Padrino.
Prometió regresar
cuando el niño fuese adulto
para traerle felicidad y prosperidad.
El padre, sabiendo que todas
las personas son iguales ante la Muerte,
aceptó la oferta.
Años después, cuando el niño
se había convertido un joven ambicioso,
la esquelética figura del Padrino
vino a su prometida visita.
En su mano callosa
sostenía un recipiente
que contenía la cura
para todos los males humanos.
La Muerte había traído
ese recipiente para su Ahijado
y le prometió convertirlo
en un exitoso doctor.
Pero la poderosa poción
venía con reglas muy estrictas.
Si su Ahijado se encontraba
a una persona enferma
y la Muerte rondaba
a la cabeza de su cama,
el doctor podría curarla con apenas
una ráfaga de los vapores del antídoto.
Pero si la Muerte se hallaba
al pie de la cama,
el paciente ya estaría en su poder,
y el doctor no podría hacer nada.
Con el tiempo, la potente poción
del doctor y sus misteriosos instintos
cobraron fama por todo el territorio.
Se hizo rico y famoso, y olvidó
las penurias de sus primeros años.
Cuando el rey se enfermó, convocó
al famoso doctor para que lo atendiera.
El doctor se apresuró a ir al palacio,
listo para mostrar sus habilidades.
Pero al entrar a la recámara del rey,
se horrorizó al ver a la Muerte
alojada al pie de la cama.
El doctor quería desesperadamente
la gloria de salvar al rey,
aunque ello supusiera
engañar a su Padrino.
Entonces, rápidamente, giró la cama
e invirtió la posición de la Muerte,
tras lo cual le era posible
administrar el antídoto.
La Muerte estaba furiosa.
Le advirtió a su arrogante Ahijado
que si volvía a engañar a la Muerte,
pagaría con su propia vida.
La Muerte y el doctor
continuaron con sus viajes.
Después de un tiempo,
los mensajeros del rey volvieron
en busca del doctor una vez más.
La princesa estaba gravemente enferma,
y el rey había prometido riquezas
increíbles a quien pudiese curarla.
El doctor se acercó
a la recámara de la princesa
con la mira puesta en el oro.
Pero al ver a la princesa durmiente,
su ambición desapareció.
Le impactó tanto su belleza
que no reparó en la Muerte,
que merodeaba al pie de la cama.
Curó rápidamente a la princesa.
Pero antes de que la joven
pudiese siquiera agradecerle,
la Muerte se había llevado
a su enamoradizo Ahijado.
En un instante, el palacio
se desvaneció a su alrededor.
El doctor se encontró
en una inmensa cueva
rodeado de numerosas velas parpadeantes,
cada una de las cuales
representaba la duración de una vida.
Como castigo por el desatinado intento
de su Ahijado de dominar la mortalidad,
la Muerte fue apagando su vela
hasta dejar solo la mecha.
Al ver su propia luz apagándose,
el doctor sintió el terror que tanto
había visto en los ojos de sus pacientes.
Rogó desesperadamente a la Muerte
que transfiriera su moribunda luz
a una nueva vela.
Su Padrino consideró la petición,
pero la traición del doctor
había sido demasiado grande.
Abrió su huesuda mano
y la vela de su Ahijado cayó al suelo.
La Muerte permaneció inmóvil,
con la mirada inescrutable
fija en la llama chispeante,
hasta que lo único que quedó del doctor
fueron restos de humo.